monsieur le président de la république
je vous donne la parole
monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en son article 18
la constitution permet au président de
la république de prendre la parole
devant le parlement réuni à cet effet en
congrès il est des heures qui de cette
possibilité font une nécessité les
heures que nous vivons sont de celles-là
le 7 mai dernier les français m'ont
confié un mandat clair le 18 juin
ils en ont amplifié la force en élisant
à l'assemblée nationale une large
majorité parlementaire
je veux aujourd'hui vous parler du
mandat que le peuple nous a donné des
institutions que je veux changer et des
principes d'action que j'entends suivre
ce sont mille chemins différents qui
nous ont conduits ici aujourd'hui vous
et moi
animés par le même désir de servir et
même si ce désir n'a pas le même visage
pas la même forme même s'il n'en porte
pas les mêmes conséquences
nous en connaissons vous et moi la
source
ce simple amour de la patrie
certains font de la politique depuis
longtemps
pour d'autres au nombre desquels je me
range ce n'est pas le cas vous
soutiendrez vous combattrez selon vos
convictions
le gouvernement que j'ai nommé mais à la
fin nous savons tous que quelque chose
de très profond nous réunir nous anime
et nous engage oui
le simple amour de la patrie que
celle-ci s'incarne dans la solitude des
collines de haute provence où des
ardennes dans la tristesse des grands
ensembles où une partie de notre
jeunesse s'abîme dans la campagne
parfois dur à vivre et à travailler dans
les déserts industriels mais aussi dans
la gaieté surprenante des commencements
de cet amour nous tirons tous je crois
la même impatience qui est une
impatience d'agir elle prend parfois les
traits de l'optimisme volontaire
d'autres fois ce d'une colère sincère
toujours elle découle de cette même
origine nous avons vous et moi reçu le
mandat du peuple qui nous ait été donné
par la nation entière ou par les
électeurs d'une circonscription ne
change rien à sa force qu'il était est
porté par le suffrage direct ou par le
suffrage indirect ne change rien à sa
nature qu'il était obtenu voici un
certain temps déjà
ou bien récemment à l'issue d'une
campagne toutes les opinions ont pu
s'exprimer dans leur diversité et que
vous incarniez ses opinions différentes
ici aujourd'hui ne change rien à
l'obligation collective qui pèse sur
nous
cette obligation est celle d'une
transformation résolu et profonde
tranchant avec les années immobile ou
avec les années agitées tout aux
résultats également décevant c'est par
cette voie que nous retrouverons ce qui
nous a tant manqué la confiance en nous
la force nécessaire pour accomplir nos
idéaux ce qui nous est demandé par le
peuple
c'est de renouer avec l'esprit de
conquête qui l'a fait pour enfin le
réconcilier avec lui même en vous et 10
ans dans votre nouveauté radicale à
l'assemblée nationale
le peuple français a montré son
impatience à l'égard d'un monde
politique trop souvent fait de querelles
nous d'ambition creuse où nous avions
vécu jusqu alors
c'est aussi à une manière de voir la
politique qu'il a donné congé en
accordant leur confiance à des femmes et
des hommes ici réunis les français ont
exprimé une impérieuse attentes
la volonté d'une alternance profonde et
je suis sûr que vous êtes ici tous aussi
conscient que moi et je sais bien aussi
que les sénateurs en ont une pleine
conscience
bien que leur élection soit plus
anciennes parce qu'ils ont perçu aussi
attentif par nature aux mouvements du
temps les espoirs nouveau que
l'expression du suffrage universel
direct a fait naître être fidèle à ce
que le peuple français a voulu suppose
donc une certaine forme d'ascèse une
exigence renforcée une dignité
particulière et sans doute plus encore
aujourd'hui qu'hier les mauvaises
habitudes reviennent vite marqué par une
époque de cynisme de découragement et
j'ose le dire de platitudes nombreux
encore sont ceux qui spéculent sur un
échec qui justifieraient leur
scepticisme il vous appartiendra
il nous appartiendra de les démentir
et il nous appartiendra aussi de
convaincre tous ceux qui attendent
qu'ils nous font confiance du bout des
lèvres tous ceux qui n'ont pas voté tous
eux aussi que la colère et le dégoût
devant l'inefficacité notre inefficacité
bien souvent ont conduit vers des choix
extrêmes d'un bord ou de l'autre de
l'échiquier politique et qui sont des
choix dont la france dans sa grandeur
comme dans son bonheur n'a rien à
attendre ce mandat du peuple que nous
avons reçues
quel est il exactement pour le savoir
il faut sortir de ce climat de faux
procès où le débat public nous a
enfermés trop longtemps il nous faut
retrouver de l'air de la sérénité de
l'allant il faut un effort parce que
c'est faux procès sont nombreux
s'agit-il de réformer le droit du
travail pour libérer dynamiser l'emploi
aux bénéfices d'abord de ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas on nous dira qu'il s'agit
d'adapter la france aux cruautés de
l'univers mondialisé où de satisfaire
aux diktats de bruxelles
s'agit-il de réduire nos dépenses
publiques pour éviter à nos enfants de
payer le prix de nos renoncements
on nous dira que nous remettons en cause
notre modèle social
s'agit-il de sortir de l'état d'urgence
on nous dira d'un côté que nous laissons
la france sans défense face au
terrorisme et de l'autre que nous
bradons nos libertés eh bien rien rien
de tout cela n'est vrai derrière tous
ces faux procès on trouve le même vice
levis qui empoisonne depuis trop
longtemps le débat public le déni de
réalité
le refus de voir le réel en face dans sa
complexité et ses contraintes
l'aveuglément face à un état d'urgence
qui est autant économique et sociale que
sécuritaire là dessus j'ai toujours
considéré que le peuple français était
plus sage et plus avisés que beaucoup ne
le croit si bien que je pense
profondément que le mandat que nous
avons reçu du peuple est un mandat à la
fois exigeant et profondément réaliste
et que pour l'accomplir nous devons nous
placer au delà de la stérilité de ses
oppositions purement théorique et qui si
elles garantissent de beaux succès de
tribunes n'apporte rien notre premier
devoir est tout à la fois de retrouver
le sens et la force d'un projet
ambitieux de transformation de notre
pays et de rester arrimée au réel
de ne rien céder au principe de plaisir
oomu facile aux illusions pour regarder
en face la réalité de notre pays sous
toutes ses formes
ce mandat du peuple français donc quel
est il c'est d'abord le mandat de la
souveraineté de la nation c'est de
pouvoir disposer de soi même malgré les
contraintes c'est les dérèglements du
monde
voyons la réalité en face les forces de
l'aliénation sont extrêmement puissante
ali nations à la nouvelle division du
travail qui s'esquisse dans un univers
en transformation profonde où le
numérique recompose des secteurs entiers
de l'économie bouscule déséquilibres et
des emplois aliénation à la misère à la
pauvreté
si nous nous permettons pas à chacun de
trouver un travail qui lui corresponde
qu'il soit heureux d'accomplir une place
et une dignité qui soit la sienne dans
la société allie nation à la contrainte
financière
si nous ne rétablissons pas notre budget
si nous ne réduisons pas notre dette
publique
aliénation à la volonté d'autres pays
dans l'europe comme au sein de nos
alliances
si nous ne remettons pas nos affaires en
ordre aliénation à la terreur islamiste
si nous trouve si nous ne trouvons pas
le moyens de la détruire sans rien lui
céder de nos valeurs de nos principes
aliénation de notre avenir si nous ne
parvenons pas à organiser la transition
écologique à protéger la planète
aliénation de notre vie dans ce qu'elle
a de plus quotidien
si les aliments que nous mangeons l'air
que nous respirons l'eau que nous buvons
nous sont imposées et pour le pire par
les seules forces d'une compétition
internationale
devenu anarchique je crois fermement que
sur tous ces points le peuple nous a
donné le mandat de lui rendre sa pleine
souveraineté
mais c'est aussi le mandat du projet
progressiste
d'un projet de transformation et de
changements profonds qui nous étonner
nos concitoyens ont fait le choix d'un
pays qui repartent de l'avant qui
retrouve l'optimisme et l'espoir
ils l'ont fait parce qu'ils savent bien
parce que nous savons bien que dans un
monde bouleversé par des changements
profonds sans ce mouvement sans cette
énergie créatrice la france n'est pas la
france
ils savent parce que cela a été notre
expérience commune de ces dernières
années qu'une france arrêtée s'affaisse
se divisent qu'une france a pleuré
recroqueviller et victime s'épuisant
querelles stériles et ne produit que du
malheur malheur individuelle et malheur
collectif
elle est là notre mission historique
cette mission la mienne celle du
gouvernement
la vôtre n'est pas dévolue à un petit
nombre
elle est dévolue à tous car un chacun ya
sa part la france possède des trésors de
créativité des ressources inépuisables
mais je ne pense pas simplement là à
tous nos talents
je pense à chaque française à chaque
français soucieux de bien faire et de
mener une vie digne de lui
elle est là la vraie richesse d'un pays
et le mandat qui nous est donné c'est de
créer de l'unité où il y avait de la
division de redonner à ceux qui sont
exclus la simple dignité de l'existence
leur juste place dans le projet national
de permettre à ceux qui créent inventent
innove entreprennent de réaliser leur
projet de rendre le pouvoir à ceux qui
veulent faire et font le mandat du
peuple ce n'est pas d'instaurer le
gouvernement d'une élite pour elle-même
c'est de rendre au peuple
cette dignité collective qui ne
s'accompagne d'aucune exclusion
seulement voilà jusqu'ici trop souvent
nous avons fait fausse route
nous avons préféré les procédures aux
résultats
le règlement à l'initiative la société
de la renta la société de la justice et
je crois profondément que par ses choix
récents notre peuple nous demande
d'emprunter une voie radicalement
nouvelle je refuse pour ma part de
choisir entre l'ambition et l'esprit de
justice
je refuse ce dogme que pour bâtir
l'égalité il faudrait renoncer à
l'excellence pas plus que pour réussir
il nous faut renoncer à donner une place
à chacun le sel même de notre république
est de savoir conjuguer ses exigences
oui de faire tout cela en quelque sorte
en même temps cette voie désoriente je
l'entends bien tous ceux qui s'étaient
habitués à faire carrière sur les
schémas anciens
il en est ainsi à chaque période lorsque
le renouveau s'impose et que
l'inquiétude à certains endroits peut
naître mais nous avons à prendre la
mesure des efforts que va nous imposer
cette formidable soif de renouvellement
dont nous sommes vous et moi les porter
le mandat du peuple
c'est aussi le mandat de la confiance et
de la transparence
nous sommes un vieux peuple politique la
politique est importante pour nos
concitoyens
on lui demande tout parfois trop on lui
en veut souvent parfois trop aussi
et c'est parce qu'elle est essentielle à
ce point que les français avaient fini
par s'exaspérer devoir l'espérance
confisqués mais vous êtes ici tous et
toutes les dépositaires de ce désir de
changement qui nous est interdit de
trahir et ce changement doit aussi
porter sur les comportements il ne peut
y avoir de réforme sans confiance il ne
peut y avoir de confiance si le monde
politique continue d'apparaître
même si c'est la plupart du temps
injuste comme le monde des petits
arrangements à mille lieues des
préoccupations des français
la loi que le gouvernement proposera à
vos suffrages n'a pas d'autre but nous
nous avons déjà changé depuis plusieurs
années et nous avons changé en bien
nous avons cessé de supporter ce qui
semblait presque normal autrefois
l'opacité le clientélisme les conflits
d'intérêts tout ce qui relève d'une
forme de corruption ordinaire presque
impalpable
pour autant nul n'est irréprochable car
si l'exigence doit être constante si
nous sommes tous dépositaire de la
dignité qui sied à nos fonctions et
chaque jour nous oblige la perfection
n'existe pas oui nous voulons une
société de confiance et pour cela une
loi ne suffit pas c'est un comportement
de chaque jour mais nous voulons aussi
cette confiance parce que la société de
la délation et du soupçon généralisé qui
était jusque là la conséquence de
l'impunité de quelques puissants ne nous
plaît pas davantage la loi du
gouvernement sera votée je n'en doute
pas mais après qu'elle l'aura été
j'appelle à la retenue j'appelle à en
finir avec cette recherche incessante du
scandale avec le viol permanent de la
présomption d'innocence
avec cette chasse à l'homme
ou parfois les réputations sont
détruites et où la reconnaissance de
l'innocence des mois des années plus
tard ne fait pas le dixième du bruit
qu'avait fait la mise en accusation
initial cette frénésie qui a touché tous
les camps depuis tant de mois parfois
tant d'années est indigne de nous et des
principes de la république
le mandat du peuple
c'est enfin le mandat de la fidélité
historique
les français demandent à leur
gouvernement de rester fidèle à
l'histoire de la france encore faut-il
s'entendre sur le sens que l'on donne à
ses mots ces dernières années l'histoire
a été prise en otage par le débat
politique
nous avons vu fleurir l'histoire pro
coloniale et celle de la repentance
l'histoire identitaire et celle
multiculturelle l'histoire fermé
l'histoire ouverte
il n'appartient pas au pouvoir exécutif
ou législatifs de décréter le roman
national que l'on veuille lui donner une
forme réactionnaire ou une forme
progressiste
cela ne signifie pas que l'histoire de
france n'existe pas qu'il ne faut pas en
être fier tout en regardant lucidement
ses parts d'ombrés bassesse mais pour
nous elle doit prendre la forme non d'un
commentaire non d'une revendication ou
d'une transformation mais d'une action
résolue en faveur du meilleur parce que
c'est dans cette action que nous pouvons
retrouver les grands exemples du passé
nous en nourrir et les prolonger et à la
fin nous aussi nous aussi nous aurons
fait l'histoire sans nous être réclamés
abusivement de ce qu'elle pourrait être
mais en regardant le réel
et en gardant nos esprits et nos
volontés tendue vers le meilleur c'est
ce que nous appelons le progressisme ce
n'est pas de penser que toute nouveauté
est forcément bonne ce n'est pas
d'épouser toutes les modes du temps
c'est à chaque moment pas après pas de
discerner ce qui doit être corrigé un an
des rectifier ce qui à certains endroits
doit être plus profondément refonder ce
qu'il manque à la société pour devenir
plus juste et plus efficace
ou plus exactement plus juste parce que
plus efficace plus efficace parce que
plus juste
c'est une éthique de l'action et de la
responsabilité partagée
c'est la fidélité à notre histoire et à
notre projet républicain en actes
car la république ce n'est pas des lois
figé les principes abstraits
c'est un idéal de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité
chaque jour russe culte et et repenser à
l'épreuve du réel
l'action politique n'a de sens que si
elle est précisément accompli au nom
d'une certaine idée de l'homme de son
destin de sa valeur indépassable et de
sa grandeur
cette idée la france apporte depuis
longtemps
rien d'autre ne doit compter à nos yeux
ce n'est pas la société des
entrepreneurs que nous voulons ou la
société de l' équilibre des finances
publiques où la société de l'innovation
tout cela est bien tout cela est utile
mais ce ne sont que des instruments au
service de la seule cause qui vaille une
cause à laquelle le nom de la france est
attachée depuis bien longtemps et cette
cause est la cause de l'homme nous
différons entre nous
ici même sur les moyens mais je suis sûr
que nous ne nous défilerons pas sur ce
but et le savoir et nous le rappeler
sans cesse parfois dans les pires
moments devrait rendre à notre débat
public
cette dignité cette grandeur qui sur
fond de temps d'abandon et d'échec
collectif lui ont cruellement manqué ces
dernières années
c'est à l'aune de ce mandat du peuple
que nous avons à construire notre
politique pour les cinq ans qui viennent
vous l'aurez compris et vous le savez
déjà intimement
nous n'avons pas devant nous cinq ans
d'ajustement et de demi mesure les
français ne sont pas animés par une
curiosité et patiente mais par une
exigence intransigeante
c'est la transformation profonde qu'ils
attendent qu'ils espèrent qu'ils exigent
ne la redoutons pas en bras sont là bien
au contraire la charte de notre action a
été fixée durant la campagne et vous en
connaissez les jalons sur lesquelles je
ne reviendrai pas les engagements seront
tenus les réformes et ses
transformations profondes auxquelles je
me suis engagé seront conduites le
premier ministre edouard philippe que
j'ai nommé afin qu'il soit le
dépositaire à la tête du gouvernement de
ses engagements en présentera la mise en
oeuvre dans son discours de politique
générale mais tout cela
tout cela ne sera possible que si nous
avons une république forte et il n'est
pas de république forte sans institution
puissante n'est de 32 temps troublés nos
institutions sont résistantes aux crises
et aux turbulences
elles ont démontré leur solidité mais
comme toutes les institutions elles sont
aussi
ce que les hommes en font depuis
plusieurs décennies maintenant l'esprit
qui les a fait naître s'est abîmé au gré
des renoncements et des mauvaises
habitudes en tant que garant du bon
fonctionnement des pouvoirs publics
j'agirai en suivant trois principes
l'efficacité la représentativité et la
responsabilité
l'efficacité d'abord il nous faut du
temps pour penser la loi du temps pour
la concevoir la discuter et la beauté du
temps aussi pour s'assurer des bonnes
conditions de son application souhaiter
que nos institutions soient plus
efficaces
ce n'est donc pas sacrifier au culte de
la vitesse c'est rendre la priorité aux
résultats sachons mettre un terme à la
prolifération législatives cette maladie
nous la connaissons elle a été en étant
nommé et je crains moi même dans une vie
antérieure d'y avoir participé
elle affaiblit la loi qui perd dans
l'accumulation des textes une part de sa
vigueur et certainement de son sens
telles circonstances telles imprévu
telle nouveauté ne saurait dicter le
travail du législateur
car la loi n'est pas faite pour
accompagner servilement les petits pas
de la vie de notre pays
elle est faite pour en encadrer les
tendances profondes les évolutions
importantes les débats essentiels et
pour donner un cap
elle accompagne de manière évidente les
débuts d'un mandat mais légiférer -
ensuite c'est consacrer plus d'attention
aux textes fondamentaux à ses lois
venant répondre un vide juridique
venant éclairer une situation inédite
c'est cela le rôle du parlement
légiférer moins
c'est mieux allouer le temps
parlementaire c'est en particulier
réservé de ce temps au contrôle et à
l'évaluation
je sais que nombre d'entre vous ont déjà
beaucoup réfléchi et je ne mésestime pas
les progrès faits durant ces dernières
années en la matière mais nous devons
aller plus loin encore car voter la loi
ne saurait être le premier et le dernier
geste du parlement nos sociétés sont
devenues trop complexe et trop rapide
pour qu'un texte de loi produit ses
pleins effets sans se heurter lui-même
au principe de réalité
la voix des citoyens concernés par les
textes que vous votez ne saurait être
perçu comme attentatoire à la dignité du
législateur élite la vie et le réel
elle est ce pour quoi vous oeuvrez nous
oeuvrons c'est pourquoi bien suivre
l'application d'une loi s'assurer de sa
pertinence dans la durée de ses effets
dans le temps pour la corriger ou il
revenir est aujourd'hui devenue une
ardente obligation pour toutes ces
raisons je souhaite qu'une évaluation
complète de tous les textes importants
comme aujourd'hui celle sur le dialogue
social ou encore sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme dont nous avons récemment
jeté les bases soient menées dans les
deux ans suivant leur mise en
application
il est même souhaitable qu'on évalue
l'utilité des lois plus anciennes afin
d'ouvrir la possibilité d'abroger des
lois qui aurait par le passé était trop
vite adopté mal construites ou dont
l'existence aujourd'hui représenterait
un frein à la bonne marche de la société
française enfin le rythme de conception
des lois doit savoir répondre aux
besoins de la société
il est des situations d'urgence que le
rythme propre travail parlementaire ne
permet pas de traiter suffisamment vite
songer à l'encadrement des pratiques
issues du numérique en matière de
protection des droits d'auteur de la vie
privée de nos concitoyens
ou de la sécurité nationale notre temps
collectif est aujourd'hui trop lent il
faut qu'au temps long du travail
législatif que je viens d'évoquer soit
ajoutée la faculté d'agir vite
ainsi la navette pourrait être simplifié
je pense même que vous devriez pouvoir
dans les cas les plus simples voter la
loi en commission
tout cela vous y avez pour nombre
d'entre vous beaucoup travaillé tout
cela doit être sérieusement étudié mais
pour désormais le faire je n'ignore rien
des contraintes qui pèsent sur vous le
manque de moyens le manque d' équipe
le manque d espace contrarie en partie
les impératifs d'efficacité que je vous
soumets pour cela il est une mesure
depuis longtemps souhaitée par nos
compatriotes qu'il me semble
indispensable de mettre en oeuvre la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires un
parlement moins nombreux mais renforcé
dans ses moyens
c'est un parlement où le travail devient
plus fluide où les parlementaires
peuvent s'entourer de collaborateurs
mieux formés plus nombreux c'est un
parlement qui travaille mieux
c'est pourquoi je proposerai une
réduction d'un tiers du nombre des
membres des trois assemblées
constitutionnel je suis convaincu que
cette mesure aura des effets favorables
pour la qualité générale du travail
parlementaire
ça n'est pas céder à l'anti
parlementarisme ambiant bien au
contraire car les français pour leur
majeure partie en sont également
certains cette réforme est indispensable
cette réforme qui devra être conduite en
veillant à la juste représentation de
tous les territoires de la république
hexagonaux et ultra marins n'a pas pour
but de nourrir cet anti parlementarisme
ambiant
elle vise à donner aux élus de la
république
plus de moyens et plus de poids le
devoir d' efficacité ne saurait peser
seulement sur le parlement l'exécutif
doit entendre sa part est d'abord
précisément vis-à-vis du parlement c'est
pourquoi mesdames et messieurs les
parlementaires
j'ai voulu vous réservez et à travers
vous aux français
ma première expression politique depuis
mon élection
trop de mes prédécesseurs se sont vu
reprocher de n'avoir pas fait la
pédagogie de leurs actions ni d'avoir
exposé le sens et le cap de leur mandat
trop d'entre eux aussi ont pris des
initiatives dont le parlement n'était
que secondaire m'en informer pour que je
me satisfasse de reconduire la méthode
tous les ans je reviendrai donc devant
vous pour vous rendre compte
et si la considération et la
bienveillance que cela traduit à l'égard
du parlement apparaît à certains comme
une dérive condamnable c'est sans doute
qu'ils ont de leur rôle de parlementaire
et du rôle du président de la république
une conception vague que masquent mal
l'arrogance doctrinaire ou le sectarisme
il est toujours préoccupante que des
représentants du peuple se soustraient
aux règles de la constitution qui les a
fait élire
sieyès et mirabaud ne désespère pas je
crois si promptement le mandat que leur
avait confié le peuple le président de
la république doit fixer le sens du
quinquennat et c'est ce que je suis venu
faire devant vous il revient au premier
ministre qui dirige l'action du
gouvernement de lui donner corps c'est à
lui qu'incombe la lourde tâche d'assurer
la cohérence des actions de conduire les
transformations de rendre les arbitrages
et avec les ministres
de vous les présenter je souhaite que
cette responsabilité est un sens c'est
pourquoi je demanderai au premier
ministre d'assigner à chacun des
objectifs clairs dont annuellement
ils lui rendront compte de même
l'efficacité commande que les ministres
soient au coeur de l'action publique et
retrouvent avec leur administration un
contact plus direct
la réduction que j'ai voulu à 10 du
nombre de collaborateurs de cabinet
comme le renouvellement de l'ensemble
des directeurs d'administration centrale
répondre à cette priorité il s'agit de
rendre aux directeurs d'administrations
disposant alors de la pleine confiance
du gouvernement
la connaissance directe de la politique
qu'ils auront à mettre en oeuvre et de
partager ainsi au sein du gouvernement
et de toute l'administration
cette responsabilité partagée dont le
peuple nous a fixé le cap soumis eux
mêmes à l'obligation de résultat par la
feuille de route qui les lie au premier
ministre les ministres ne perdrons pas
de vue pour autant les conditions de
mise en oeuvre de leurs politiques
je veux à cet effet une administration
plus déconcentré qui conseille plus qu
elle ne sanctionne qui innovent et
expérimentent plus qu'elle ne contraigne
tel est le cercle vertueux de
l'efficacité
c'est cette administration qui doit
redonner à tous les territoires les
moyens d'agir et de réussir car à la fin
notre démocratie ne se nourrit que de
l'action et de notre capacité à changer
le quotidien et le réel
mais ce souci d'efficacité ne suffira
pas à rendre à notre démocratie
l'oxygène dont trop longtemps il fut
privé
s'il faut en finir avec la république
inefficace
il faut en finir aussi bien avec la
république du souffle court des petits
calculs de la routine
nous nous retrouverons la respiration
profonde de la démocratie que dans le
renouement avec la variété du réel avec
la diversité de cette société française
à l'égard de laquelle nos institutions
se sont trop soigneusement tenus
n'admettant le changement que pour les
autres mais pas pour elle la réalité est
plurielle la vie est plurielle le
pluralisme s'impose à nos institutions
qui s'affaiblissent dans l'autre soit
nous avons fait entrer ici la grande
diversité française elle est sociale
professionnelle géographique de genre
est d'origine d'âge et d'expérience de
croyance et d'engagement elle constitue
un alliage inédit de compétences et de
destin dont vous êtes aujourd'hui les
visages mais tout cela n'a pas été
composé comme un nuancier savants nous
avons simplement ouvert les portes aux
citoyens auxquels le monde politique
refuser l'accès je souhaite que ce
renouvellement celle le retour du débat
que n'avait que ne veulent pas les
dogmes du partage d'idées que ne
dénature pas le caporalisme c'est aussi
pour cela que je crois à la vertu du
pluralisme au respect plein et entier
des oppositions
non parce qu'il s'agirait d'un usage
mais car c'est la dignité du débat
démocratique et cela sera notre ardente
responsabilité la représentativité reste
toutefois un combat inachevé dans notre
pays
je souhaite le mener avec vous
résolument je proposerai ainsi que le
parlement soit élu avec une dose de
proportionnelle pour que toutes les
sensibilités
ils soient justement représentés c'est à
cette même fin que nous limiterons le
cumul des mandats dans le temps pour les
parlementaires car il s'agit là de la
clé de voûte d'un renouvellement qui ne
se produira pas sous la pression et
l'exaspération citoyenne mais deviendra
le rythme normal de la respiration
démocratique
les parlementaires eux-mêmes verrons
dans leur mandat
une chance de faire avancer le pays et
non plus la clé d'un cursus avis il est
d'autres institutions de la république
que le temps a figé dans des situations
acquises
quand le sens véritable de leur mission
utt d'incarner le mouvement vivant de la
société française le conseil économique
social et environnemental et de celle
fille sa mission était de créer entre la
société civile et les instances
politiques
un trait d'union fait du dialogue
constructif et de proposition suivie
d'effet cette intention fondatrice
c'est un peu perdu je souhaite qu'on
renoue avec elle le conseil économique
social et environnemental doit devenir
la chambre du futur où circuleront
toutes les forces vives de la nation
pour cela nous devons revoir tout en
réduisant le nombre de ses membres d'un
tiers de fond en comble les règles de sa
représentativité
celle ci étant acquise nous ferons de
cette assemblée le carrefour des
consultations publiques et le seul
l'état ne travaille pas ne réforme pas
sans consulter et c'est bien normal mais
les instances de consultation se sont
multipliés nous ne savons même plus les
dénombrer elles ont toutes leur
justification de représenter une part
vibrante de la société civile mais
c'était le rôle initial du conseil
économique social et environnemental en
le réformant nous en ferons l'instance
unique de consultation prévue par tous
nos textes
cela sera un élément d'une plus grande
représentativité de notre société civile
et dans le même temps un élément de
simplification de nos procédures de
simplification de la fabrique de la loi
ce conseil doit pouvoir devenir le forum
de notre république
réunir toutes les sensibilités et toutes
les compétences et donner un lieu en
quelque sorte à l'expression de toutes
les sensibilités du monde de
l'entreprise et du travail des
entrepreneurs comme des syndicats des
salariés comme des indépendants mais
aussi des associations et des
organisations non gouvernementales
dans le même temps je souhaite que le
droit de pétition soit revu afin que
l'expression directe de nos concitoyens
soient mieux prises en compte et que les
propositions des français puissent être
présentés dans un cadre défini et
construit à la représentation nationale
là aussi
il en va de la représentativité de notre
démocratie
une représentativité qui ne vivrait pas
seulement une fois tous les cinq ans
mais au quotidien dans l'action du
législateur fondée sur une
représentativité plus grande
animé par le souci d'efficacité le débat
démocratique et plus particulièrement le
débat parlementaire retrouveront j'en
suis sûr
leur vitalité le désir d'agir et de
faire avancer la société reprendra son
rang premier au sein de nos institutions
et il rejoindra cet autre principe
souverain dont trop souvent nous nous
somme des parties
celui de responsabilité une activité
parlementaire
revivifiée par un cap clair des débats
mieux construits c'est un parlement plus
apte à exercer sa mission de contrôle
sans laquelle la responsabilité de
l'exécutif ne vit pas est affaibli je
souhaite qu'au parlement la majorité
comme les oppositions puisse avoir
encore davantage de moyens pour donner
un contour est une exigence à la
responsabilité politique de l'exécutif
les ministres eux-mêmes doivent devenir
comptable des actes accomplis dans leurs
fonctions ordinaire c'est pour cette
raison que je souhaite la suppression de
la cour de justice de la république
il faudra trouver la bonne organisation
mais nos concitoyens ne comprennent plus
pourquoi seuls les ministres pourraient
encore disposer d'une juridiction
d'exception faire vivre la
responsabilité partout dans nos
institutions c'est aussi assurer
l'indépendance pleine et entière de la
justice c'est une ambition qui doit
demeurer malgré les impasses et les
demis échecs rencontrés dans le passé je
souhaite à cette fin que nous
accomplissions enfin cette séparation de
l'exécutif et du judiciaire en
renforçant le rôle du conseil supérieur
de la magistrature
tueur et en limitant l'intervention de
l'exécutif dans les nominations des
magistrats du parquet à tout le moins ce
conseil devrait donner un avis conforme
pour toutes les nominations de ces
magistrats
c'est un changement profond des
pratiques et des règles que j'appelle de
mes voeux
je ne méconnais pas l'évolution
institutionnelle et constitutionnelle
que cela requiert
c'est pourquoi je demanderai à madame la
garde des sceaux et aux ministres
compétents ainsi qu'aux présidents des
deux chambres de me faire pour l'automne
des propositions concrètes permettant
d'atteindre cet objectif
je souhaite que la totalité des
transformations profondes que je viens
de détail et aidons nos institutions ont
cruellement besoin soit parachevée d'ici
un an et que l'on se garde des demi
mesures et des aménagements cosmétiques
ces réformes seront soumises à votre
vote
mais si cela est nécessaire je recourait
aux votes de nos concitoyens par voie de
référendum car il s'agit ici de rien
moins que de retisser entre les français
la république le rapport qui s'est
dissout dans l'exercice mécanique du
pouvoir je veux réveiller avec vous le
sens du pacte civique
je veux que l'efficacité la
représentativité et la responsabilité
face témergie clairement et fortement
une république contractuelle la
confiance accordée il va de pair avec
les comptes courants
l'action s'y déploie dans un cadre
partagé entre le mandataire et le
mandant et non au fil des circonstances
et c'est cela le sens du contrat social
qui fondent la république ce que nous
ferons
pour les institutions de la république
je souhaite le faire aussi pour nos
territoires ne redoute ont pas de nouer
avec les territoires des accords de
confiance nous savons tous combien notre
france est diverse
combien est importante l'intimité des
décideurs publics avec le terrain de
leurs actions la centralisation jacobine
traduit trop souvent la peur élémentaire
de perdre une part de son pouvoir
conjurons la hoz ont expérimenté des
concentrés c'est indispensable pour les
territoires ruraux comme pour les
quartiers difficiles
osons conclure avec nos territoires et
nos élus devraient pacte girondins fondé
sur la confiance et la responsabilité
la conférence des territoires qui sera
bientôt lancée et conduite par le
premier ministre répond à cette
préoccupation
il ne s'agira pas uniquement d'une
conférence budgétaire ou financière mais
de trouver ensemble les moyens d'adapter
nos politiques aux réalités locales et
je pense en particulier aux
collectivités d'outre-mer qui doivent
avoir tous les moyens pour réussir
c'est ce même esprit de confiance qui
fondent cette république contractuelle
que d'ores et déjà nous faisons avancer
dans la société et le monde du travail
en donnant à celles et ceux qui sont au
plus près de la réalité de l'entreprise
une capacité plus grande à réguler le
quotidien nous dans le rapport de force
mais dans un cadre nouveau et partager
nous savons tous et toutes que la
confiance exige un soin plus grand que
l'usagé unilatéral de l'autorité nous
savons aussi qu'elle produit de plus
grands résultats et qu'elle suscite
cette concorde sans laquelle il n'est
pas de vie civile supportable
la france a vécu assez d'épreuves connu
assez de grandeur pour n'être pas ce
peuple enfants que l'on bercent
d'illusions
chaque français à sa part de
responsabilité et son rôle à jouer dans
la conquête à venir en retrouvant
l'esprit de nos institutions
nous redonnerons à la nation tout
entière le sentiment de retrouver la
maîtrise de son destin
la fierté de reprendre en main le fil de
son histoire
c'est la condition même de la
réconciliation de notre pays pour être
au rendez vous que le peuple nous a
donné il ne nous est pas permis
d'attendre
c'est pourquoi j'aurais besoin pour
notre république de la mobilisation de
tous autour de quelques grands principes
d'action il ne s'agit pas ici pour moi
de décliner l'action du gouvernement
comme certains se plaisent à le craindre
ou à le souhaiter
c'est la tâche du premier ministre c'est
le sens même et la force de nos
institutions et je ne gagnerai pas ici
non plus tous les secteurs les métiers
les territoires que chacun sache
néanmoins que ces grands principes parle
pour tous le premier principe doit être
la recherche d'une liberté forte en
matière économique sociale territoriale
culturel notre devoir est d'émanciper
nos concitoyens c'est à dire leur
permettre de ne pas subir leur vie mais
bien d'être en situation de la choisir
de pouvoir faire là où trop souvent nos
règles entrave au prétexte de protéger
je crois à cet esprit des lumières qui
fait que notre objectif à la fin et bien
l'autonomie de l'homme libre
conscient et critique trop de nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui se sentent
prisonniers de leur origine sociale de
leurs conditions d'une trajectoire
qu'ils subissent or l'enclavement
l'isolément l'absence d'accès aux
transports à toutes les formes des
nécessités de ce siècle nouveau assignée
à résidence
des millions de nos compatriotes la
liberté forte que nous avons à bâtir
c'est ce combat pour toutes les
mobilités ce combat pour les ex époux
les accès ce combat pour que nul ne donc
concitoyens ne souhaite exclus des voies
du progrès du droit de faire d'essayer
pour échouer peut-être ou pour réussir
c'est le combat de notre mobilité
économique et sociale par le travail et
par l'effort pour tous nos concitoyens
quelles que soient leurs quartiers leurs
prénoms leur origine c'est le combat
pour l'égalité pleine entre les femmes
et les hommes
ce beau combat dans notre pays a perdu
quelques jours quelques jours à peine
une figure essentielle en madame simone
veil la liberté forte c'est la liberté
de choisir sa vie car la liberté ce qui
réconcilie précisément la justice et
l'efficacité la possibilité de faire et
l'égalité vraie la liberté
d'expérimenter de se tromper d'essayer
encore on embarque plus dans son
existence pour un voyage au long cours
nos vies sont exploration tentative
recherche
sachons inventé cette liberté là avec
les nouvelles protections individuelles
qui l'accompagnent en assurant
l'éducation la formation les sécurités
utile aux grandes étapes de la vie
précisément pour construire une
existence
c'est tout le sens des transformations
économiques et sociales profondes que le
gouvernement aura à conduire dans les
prochains mois libéré et protégé
permettre d'innover en construisant une
place pour chacun et je souhaite qu'il
ne cède rien aux fausses promesses ni à
celle d'une liberté qu'ils oublient
qu'ils oublieraient toutes les sécurités
individuel car à la fin elle promet le
malheur ni la société des statuts qui au
nom des règles acquise prétend protéger
quand entêtant sont au bord de la route
quand le chômage est au niveau qu'on lui
connaît et l'exclusion
là où elle est vouloir la liberté forte
c'est tout cela en ces temps de
terrorisme
vouloir la liberté forte c'est aussi
assurer la liberté de chacun et garantir
le plein respect des libertés
individuelles
[Musique]
je veux ici vous parler avec franchise
de ce que trop souvent on n'ose pas
nommé le terrorisme islamiste et les
moyens de le combattre
que devons-nous aux victimes
que devons-nous à nos compatriotes qui
sont morts que devons-nous à la france
en deuil et par ces assassinats marqué
du sceau de la lâcheté de la bêtise de
l'aveuglément certainement pas de nous
limiter à l'esprit victimaire où est la
seule commémoration nous leur devons la
fidélité à nous mêmes à nos valeurs à
nos principes renoncer c'est concédé au
nihilisme des assassins sa plus belle
victoire
d'un côté je rétablirai les libertés des
français en levant l'état d'urgence à
l'automne parce que ces libertés sont la
condition de l'existence d'une
démocratie forte parce que les
abandonner c'est apporter à nos
adversaires
une confirmation que nous devons leur
refuser de tout temps
les adversaires de la démocratie ont
prétendu qu'elle était faible et que si
elle voulait combattre
il lui faudrait bien abandonner ses
grands principes c'est exactement le
contraire qui est vrai le code pénal tel
qu'il est les pouvoirs des magistrats
tels qu'ils sont peuvent fille le
système est bien ordonnée bien organisé
nous permettre d'anéantir nos
adversaires donné en revanche à
l'administration des pouvoirs illimités
sur la vie des personnes sans aucune
discrimination n'a aucun sens ni en
termes de principes ni en termes
d'efficacité mais d'un autre côté je
souhaite que le parlement puisse voter
ces dispositions nouvelles qui nous
renforcerons encore dans notre lutte
elles devront viser explicitement les
terroristes à l'exclusion de tous les
autres français
quelques portes elles comporteront des
mesures renforcées mais qui seront
placés sous la surveillance du juge dans
le respect intégral et permanent de nos
exigences constitutionnelles et de nos
traditions de liberté la démocratie n'a
pas été conçue simplement pour les temps
calmes elle vaut surtout pour les
moments d'épreuve il est là le chemin de
l'efficacité et c'est le même chemin que
celui des valeurs un pays rassemblés
unis sur ses principes
une société pleinement consciente de ce
qui la fonde sont invincibles
tel est exactement le sens profond des
textes que vous aurez à examiner il vise
à nous libérer de la peur de
l'aliénation à la volonté de nos
adversaires nous travaillerons à
prévenir tout nouvel attentat et nous
travaillerons à les réprimer sans pitié
sans remords sans faiblesse avec
d'autant plus de force que nous
n'ouvrons céder sur rien de ce qui nous
constitue
j'en prends l'engagement ici devant vous
et au delà devant le peuple français
répondre aux terroristes ce n'est pas
changer notre constitution chaque matin
ça n'est pas renoncer aux principes de
notre république parce que rappelons le
c'est au plus fort de la guerre
d'algérie qu'a été construite écrite
voter cette disposition de notre
constitution qui prévoit précisément que
l'autorité judiciaire et la gardienne de
nos libertés alors montrons nous dignes
aujourd'hui de la fermeté d'âme de ceux
qui nous ont précédés dans les épreuves
enfin la liberté forte c'est toujours en
france la liberté de conscience
c'est à dire la liberté intellectuelle
morale spirituelle et de cette liberté
la france doit être l'indispensable
havre l'éducation et la culture en sont
les clés elles sont au coeur de notre
action car en cette matière rien n'est
jamais acquis
les progrès de l'obscurantisme nous
rappelle ainsi à l'idéal des lumières et
la laïcité en est l'indispensable
corollaire à ses principes et à ses
ambitions
la république a su ne rien céder car ils
sont la condition même de l'autonomie de
nos concitoyens de cette culture
libérale ouverte généreuse nous devons
refaire ensemble
la singularité de la france car c'est
par là que toujours elle su rayonner au
sein de la culture mondialisée et dont
on observe la prolifération parfois
inquiétante la voix de la france et de
la culture françaises doivent occuper
une place éminente associant tous les
français de métropole et d'outre-mer
mais cette liberté ne se tiendraient pas
si notre deuxième principe d'action
n'était de retrouver le socle de notre
fraternité notre peuple n'est pas formé
d'un peu plus de 60 millions d'individus
qui cohabiterait il est indivisible
précisément parce que ceux qui le tient
est plus fort que de simples règles ou
que des organisations
c'est un engagement chaque jour répétées
qui fait que notre citoyenneté n'est
jamais abstraite et froide mais qu'elle
est pleine et entière par ce lien
fraternel qui nous unit est donc devons
retrouver la vigueur
l'un des drames de notre pays c'est que
cet engagement est tout simplement
impossible pour ce que les
dysfonctionnements de nos système
sclérosé rejette en permanence à ses
marges il nous reviendra au cours de ce
quinquennat de prendre la vraie mesure
de cette question de redéfinir nos
moyens d'action sans nous laisser
arrêter par de vieilles habitudes en
associant l'état les collectivités les
associations les fondations l'ensemble
des françaises et des français engagés
bien souvent bénévoles toutes les
entités qui privés ou publics oeuvrent à
l'intérêt général et pour la dignité des
personnes
nous devons substituer à l'idée d' aides
sociales à la charité publique aux
dispositifs parcellaire une vraie
politique de l'inclusion de tous la
représentation nationale
il trouvera un enjeu un défi à sa mesure
ne vous y trompez pas cette question est
sans doute la plus profonde la plus
sérieuse qui soit parce que notre
société est aujourd'hui divisée entre
les égoïsmes tenter par les sirènes de
la mondialisation qui voudraient faire
croire qu'on peut réussir à quelques-uns
que les nomades en quelque sorte
dicterait leur loi et de l'autre côté
les donneurs de leçons les tenants d'une
morale sans bras qui voudrait qu'on
oublie toutes les contraintes du réel
pour s'occuper d'une partie de la
société
il n'y aura pas de réussite française
si chacune et chacun n'y a pas sa place
si la pauvreté pour mettre un nom sur
cette réalité
si toutes celles et ceux qui vivent dans
la misère dans l'exclusion qui sont
privés de cette route auguste que
peuvent emprunter quelques-uns n'ont pas
aussi leur place et cela c'est notre
devoir
cela passera par des réformes
économiques et sociales profondes que
vous aurez à décider et à voter elles
sont indispensables et elles permettront
de redonner cette énergie sans laquelle
notre société n'est rien mais il faudra
aussi savoir trouver pour ce que georges
bataille appelée notre part maudite une
place une considération une vraie
réponse
enfin
car en définitive le sentiment
d'appartenance existe moins qu'avant nos
sociétés modernes en tendance à se
fractionner au gré des intérêts des
égoïsmes des idées de chacun
et là encore il nous revient dans
l'action publique de résister aux forces
de division aux effets de dislocation
qui sont à l'oeuvre et qui ne sont
aucunement invincible pour peu qu'on
s'en donne les moyens
aussi notre solidarité doit-elle
retrouver ses formes concrètes l'école
on est le premier creuser notre
université
ensuite nous famille également notre
culture la langue l'accès au savoir
l'ouverture à des possibles qui nous
rassemble forge d'un peuple et c'est
solidarité organique que nous avons mais
estimé
c'est aussi ce qui tient notre société
et face à la crise morale et de
civilisation que nous vivons nous devons
savoir forget à nouveau ses solidarité
profonde et un imaginaire puissant et
désirable où chacun trouvera sa place
c'est aussi cela la réponse que nous
devons apporter à ce qui corrompt la
société je parlais tout à l'heure du
terrorisme islamiste
il ya bien sûr la réponse sécuritaire
mais elle ne sera rien où elle ne sera
qu'une poursuite de chaque jour si par
l'éducation la culture la morale
profonde au sens plein du terme qui
doivent infuser notre société notre
imaginaire collectif et notre solidarité
à nouveau nous ne décidons pas de
rebâtir ce qui nous tient comme un
peuple
dont l'histoire et cette énergie
profondes ce qui lui a permis de relever
tant et tant de drames et de ne jamais
ça fait c'est la réponse à tous ceux que
nous vivons
ce ne sera ni des lois ni des règlements
c'est cette dignité collective retrouvée
c'est cette volonté de faire à chaque
instant c'est cette responsabilité que
chacune et chacun porte dans la société
de redonner du sens de savoir qui nous
sommes
pourquoi nous sommes là ce qui nous
tient d'avoir à chaque instant en tête
la nature du défi qu'est le nôtre est de
ne rien céder à la lettre de l'esprit du
moment de division d'accusation c'est
tout cela
ce qui durera ce qui nous dépasse
ce qui nous a fait ce qui nous a forgé
le troisième principe d'action de notre
mobilisation sera de redonner place à
l'intelligence française étant
l'intelligence je pense évidemment au
rand découverte aux chercheurs à nos
grands physiciens à nos grands médecins
aux inventeurs aux innovateurs à tout ce
qui fait et a fait la fierté de notre
pays et qui est là encore présentes
fortes sur tous les territoires qu'il
nous faut reconnaître montrer qu'il nous
faut savoir célébrer trop de fois là où
nous avons préféré jalouser je pense aux
écrivains aux philosophes aux historiens
aux cinéastes qui continuent d'apporter
au monde ce regard libre des préjugés
qui fait notre force
je pense aux peintres et aux musiciens
qui remettent au fond la politique à sa
juste place en nous faisant entrevoir un
au delà de l'existence immédiate qui
rend à la condition humaine sa grandeur
sa beauté souvent son tragique redonner
toute sa place à l'intelligence
française c'est aussi se refusait à
toutes ces incohérences qui nous mine et
nous n'y parviendrons qu'au prix d'un
véritable effort de réflexion collective
nous ne pouvons pas par exemple continué
d'affirmer hautement notre attachement
au principe de l'asile
tout en nous abstenant de réformer en
profondeur un système qui débordait de
toutes parts ne permet pas un traitement
humain et juste des demandes de
protection émanant d'hommes et femmes
menacées par la guerre et la persécution
ce qu'on appelait en 1946 les
combattants de la liberté
redonner sa place à l'intelligence
française c'est faire de notre pays
le centre d'un nouveau projet humaniste
pour le monde
le lieu où l'on concevra créera une
société qui retrouve ses équilibres la
production et la distribution plutôt que
l'accumulation par quelques-uns
l'alimentation saine et durable
la finance équitable le numérique au
service de l'homme la fin de
l'exploitation des énergies fossiles et
la réduction des émissions pas parce que
c'est à la mode
pas parce que ça ferait plaisir à
quelques-uns parce que c'est ce niveau
d'ambitions qui a toujours été le nôtre
parce que précisément c'est quand le
quotidien est difficile qu'il faut
réconcilier tendent au contraire que
tout nous pousse si nous n'écoutons que
les égoïsmes du quotidien ou le court
terme à ne pas faire que nous devons
aller de l'avant
regardez un câble fixé et le porter pour
le monde parce que c'est cela la
vocation de la france
la france n'est pas un pays qui se
réforme
c'est faux pardon monsieur le premier
ministre
de vous annoncer aujourd'hui devant le
congrès cette mauvaise nouvelle
la france est un pays qui résiste aussi
longtemps qu'il est possible de ne pas
réformer un pays qui se cabre quand on
lui parle mal quand on ne lui explique
pas quand on ne le respecte pas quand on
ne parle pas de sa dignité et son
intelligence mais c'est un pays qui face
aux défis qui à chaque fois aurait dû
l'abattre s'est profondément transformé
a su trouver en lui-même ce sens de
l'histoire de l'humanité qui a fait la
france
votre défi aujourd'hui notre défi c'est
celui là
alors vous passerez des jours des nuits
du passeront sans doute des jours et des
nuits dans des sujets qui font le
quotidien de nos concitoyens et qui sont
chacune et chacun important mais à
chaque fois ce sera cet horizon et ce
cap que nous devrons avoir à l'esprit
redonner sa place à l'intelligence
française enfin c'est comprendre que les
français sont précisément assez
intelligents pour faire leur chemin tout
seul
ce ne sont pas les français qu'il
faudrait désintoxiquer de
l'interventionnisme public c'est l'état
lui-même
il faut évidemment protéger les plus
faibles dans le droit du travail en
particulier il faut bien entendu
reconnaître la part essentielle de nos
services publics et de tous nos
fonctionnaires qui jour et nuit sans
compter leur énergie font justement
cette force mais protéger les plus
faibles
ce n'est pas les transformer en mineur
incapable on assistait permanents de
l'état de ces mécanismes de vérification
et de contrôle
c'est de leur redonner et eux seuls
les moyens de peser efficacement sur
leur destin tout sera fait pour rendre
aux français
cette autonomie qu'on leur a disputés
puis confisqué redonner sa place à
l'intelligence française c'est permettre
à chacun à chaque territoire de réussir
de s'engager
j'en viens à présent au dernier principe
de l'action que j'entends mener
construire la paix nous le savons ce
monde dans lequel nous dessinons pour la
france un chemin à la fois neuf et
fidèle à sa vocation ancien est un monde
dangereux notre environnement y compris
notre environnement proche se
caractérise par l'accumulation des
menaces c'est bien l'ombre de la guerre
qui à chaque nouvelle crise se profile
la déflagration mondiale n'est plus le
spectre que brandit seulement les
pessimistes
elle est pour les réalistes une
hypothèse sérieuse les affirmations de
puissance reviennent où émergent les
mouvements terroristes se développe dans
de multiples régions avec des moyens qui
augmentent leurs capacités de nuisance
ils sont là dans nos sociétés les
guerres régionales atteignent des degrés
et nouveaux de barbarie les alliances
d'hier s'effrite l'ordre multilatéral
doute de lui-même et les régimes
autoritaires où les démocraties
libérales fleurissent l'espace
cybernétique propage et amplifie les
instruments de ces guerres du tous
contre tous la dérive du monde impose
son rythme erratique ses excès en tous
genres détruisant l'homme le des racines
en effaçant sa mémoire
bousculant son imaginaire c'est cela le
monde dans lequel aujourd'hui nous
vivons
il ne s'agit pas de l'appréhender avec
un pessimisme des faits non cela nous
impose des devoirs les plus graves sans
doute qu'une nation puisse porter celui
de maintenir ouvertes partout la voie de
la négociation du dialogue et de la paix
face aux entreprises les plus sinistres
la vocation de la france sa fidélité à
son histoire est de savoir construire la
paix et promouvoir la dignité des
personnes
c'est pourquoi partout nous devons agir
d'abord pour protéger nos intérêts et au
premier chef notre sécurité
c'est ce qui m'a conduit réaffirmer
notre engagement au sahel comme le vent
pour lutter contre le terrorisme et
contre tous les fanatismes dans notre
intérêt comme dans celui des peuples
concernés et je sais là l'engagement de
nos forces armées
chaque jour depuis tant de mois mais une
telle action ne peut être efficace que
si elle s'inscrit dans la durée et vise
donc à construire les solutions
politiques permettant partout la sortie
de crise et donc de savoir dans toutes
ces régions
parler avec toutes les puissances y
compris celles qui ne partagent pas nos
propres finalité ou nos propres valeurs
pour trouver une issue et la construire
je ne vous proposerai pas dans ce cadre
de nous substituer à d'autres peuples
parce que nous voudrions ailleurs
imposer nos principes nos valeurs car je
ne veux pas qu apparaissent de nouveaux
états faillis toujours la france doit
respecter en même temps qu'elle lutte
contre le terrorisme et tous les excès
en même temps qu'elle protège sa propre
sécurité et ses valeurs elle doit
respecter la souveraineté des peuples
mais partout les libertés ne sont pas
respectées nous oeuvrerons à travers
notre diplomatie et nos actions de
développement afin d'aider les minorités
de travailler au service des sociétés
pour le respect des droits
cela suppose un travail exigeant parfois
longs et ingrat qui impose de replacer
la france au coeur du dialogue entre les
nations
c'est depuis plusieurs semaines ce que
je m'emploie à faire du mali à l'ukraine
et la syrie en passant par le golf en
échangeant en profondeur avec tous les
dirigeants du monde
la france doit partout
contribuer à bâtir ou rebâtir des
équilibres multiples même si parfois il
demeure fragile notre outil militaire
dans ce contexte revêt une importance
majeure
j'ai déjà ordonné une revue stratégique
de défense et de sécurité
avec comme fil directeur les principes
d'indépendance et d'autonomie de
décision
nos armées assureront les missions que
je leur ai confié la dissuasion clé de
voûte de notre sécurité la protection de
nos concitoyens et de nos intérêts
l'intervention là où le respect du droit
et de la stabilité internationales sont
menacés la prévention des crises et
leurs résolutions sera géré de manière
globale en n'oubliant jamais que seule
la stabilisation et le développement
permettent de créer les conditions d'une
paix durable
nos forces armées sont les conditions de
cette capacité de dialogue de cette
crédibilité française et de cette
capacité partout à construire la paix et
cette indépendance que j'appelle de mes
voeux ne veut pas dire pour autant
solitude
la france sera fidèle à toutes ces
alliances
les prochaines années seront pour nos
armes et celle d'un renouvellement
stratégiques et tactiques
je sais qu'elles y sont prêtes car elles
sont aux avant-postes du monde tel qu'il
va
avec cette vigilance et cet engagement
qui font honneur à notre pays vous le
voyez les menaces n'ont jamais été si
grande et l'ordre multilatérale est sans
doute plus fragilisées qui ne l'a jamais
été divisée bousculé alors plus alors
que plus que jamais il était sans doute
nécessaire dans les années à venir
le rôle de la france sera de défendre la
sécurité
l'égalité face aux excès les libertés la
planète face au réchauffement climatique
tout ce qui constitue notre bien commun
universel et qui aujourd'hui dans trop
d'endroits est remise en cause
toucher du doigt le moment inédit que
nous vivons nous sommes bâtis depuis le
xviiie siècle sur un équilibre que nous
pensions de toute éternité entre des
démocraties des valeurs libérales nos
libertés une économie de marché qui
permettait le progrès des classes
moyennes et tout cela est aujourd'hui
profondément basculer transformer menacé
des régimes autoritaires réussissent
dans l'économie de marché des
démocraties que nous croyions hier des
alliés de toujours menace l'ordre
international se met à douter de ses
propres règles
notre vocation notre rôle aujourd'hui
c'est précisément plus encore qu'hier de
les rappeler de les porter de les faire
de les tenir
c'est ce sera cela mon cap notre cas et
aucun autre secours du monde en quelque
sorte vient éprouver notre résistance et
notre cohérence c'est à titre d'exemple
ce que nous vivons dans les grandes
crises migratoires qui traversent
aujourd'hui l'afrique la méditerranée
est à nouveau l'europe les mois
prochains
nous aurons des décisions difficiles à
prendre et nous devons à la fois mieux
les prévenir par une politique de
sécurité et de développement ambitieuse
sur toutes les zones de fragilité et de
conflits nous devons ré expliquer et
agir partout quand il y à la guerre
quand il ya le réchauffement climatique
qui déstabilise
de ces régions mais nous devons aussi
mieux endiguer ces grandes migrations
par une politique de contrôle et de
lutte contre les trafics de personnes il
faut pour cela de manière coordonnée en
europe mener une action efficace et
humaine qui nous permettent d'accueillir
les réfugiés politiques qui courent un
risque réel car ce sont là nos valeurs
sans les confondre avec les migrants
économiques et abandonné l'indispensable
maîtrise de nos frontières pour réussir
à tenir ce cap nous avons besoin d'une
europe plus forte et refonder
plus que jamais nous avons besoin de
l'europe or là aussi plus que jamais
sans doute elle est affaibli par les
divisions par le doute qui s'est
installé dans notre peuple
pourtant l'europe est chez nous autant
que nous sommes en europe parce qu'il
est impossible de penser notre destinée
continental autrement qu'au travers du
projet européen l'europe l'europe c'est
nous c'est un projet de paix de liberté
de progrès qui a été pensé et agi avec
courage par des générations qui nous ont
procédé avait vécu la guerre et nous
voudrions aujourd'hui oublié tout cela
considérer que face aux divisions face
aux briques site et attend de
soubresauts de l'histoire
la réponse serait dans une diminution
encore supplémentaires dans une forme
d'abandon dans un bégaiement de
l'histoire
négliger l'europe s'habituer à la
confier à en faire le coupable de tous
nos maux c'est trahir ces générations
qui nous ont précédés c'est trahir ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
là où nous sommes nous pouvons librement
débattre de l'europe pour l'aimé ou pas
mais négligée l'europe s'habituait n'en
faire qu'un objet de négociations
techniques
c'est aussi en quelque sorte abdiqué
notre histoire et diminuer la france
la construction européenne est
aujourd'hui également il faut bien le
dire et le voir fragilisée par la
prolifération bureaucratique par le
scepticisme croissant qui en découlent
je crois fermement à l'europe mais je ne
trouve pas toujours ce scepticisme
injustifiée c'est pourquoi je vous
propose de reprendre de la hauteur de
sortir de la tyrannie des agendas et des
calendriers des méandres de la technique
la décennie qui vient de s'achever a été
pour l'europe une décennie cruel nous
avons géré des crises mais nous avons
perdu le cap
c'est pourquoi il revient à une
génération nouvelle de dirigeants de
reprendre l'idée européenne à son
origine qui est politique
dans son essence une association
volontaire réaliste et ambitieuse d'état
décidé à faire prévaloir des politiques
utiles en matière de circulation des
personnes et des biens et notamment de
la jeunesse en matière de sécurité en
matière monétaire et fiscale mais aussi
en matière politique culturelle les pays
de l'europe pour lesquelles celle ci ne
se réduit pas aux marchés mais dessine
un espace où une certaine idée de la
valeur de l'homme de l'exigence de
justice sociale sont reconnus comme
prééminent c est à la cpi doivent se
ressaisir d'un projet dé
sisyphe et s'organiser en conséquence
fut-ce au prix d'un examen sans
complaisance de notre fonctionnement
actuel nous avons une tâche au quotidien
a mené un blement gelé commencé grâce au
mandat du peuple d'avoir une europe qui
protège davantage de procéder aux
réformes indispensables de porter
l'ambition européenne dans de nombreux
sujets qui font notre quotidien mais
cela ne suffira pas il revient à la
france de prendre l'initiative et je
souhaite le faire dans les prochains
mois grâce et par le travail étroit que
j'ai d'ores et déjà engagé en
particulier avec la chancelière
d'allemagne d'ici la fin de l'année
sur ces bases partout en europe
nous lancerons des conventions
démocratique pour refonder l'europe
justement sur ce projet politique
premier sur cette ambition première qui
unit les hommes
libre à chacun ensuite d'y souscrire ou
non
mais le temps n'est plus au raccommodage
il faut reprendre l'europe à son début
si je puis dire à son origine même et
faire par la revivre le désir d'europe
en ne laissant pas le monopole du peuple
et des idées aux démagogues ou aux
extrémistes en ne faisant pas de
l'europe non plus un syndic de gestion
de crise qui cherchent chaque jour à
allonger son règlement intérieur parce
que les voisins ne se font plus
confiance
nous devons retrouver le souffle premier
de l'engagement européen
cette certitude où furent les
visionnaires des siècles passés et les
pères fondateurs de l'europe que la plus
belle part de nos histoires de nos
cultures s'exprimerait justement non
dans la rivalité encore moins dans la
guerre mais dans l'union des forces non
dans l'hégémonie de l'un ou l'autre mais
dans un équilibre respectueux qui nous
fera tous et tout réussir c'est cette
union
dans notre temps a besoin parce que
c'est cette union seul qui permettra de
relever les défis de la modernité
parce que c'est bien dans cette europe
que nous partageons une vision commune
du monde et de l'homme une vision trempé
au même source
forgée par les mêmes épreuves de
l'histoire ces défis ce sont la
transition écologique qui refonde le
rapport de l'homme et de la nature
la transition numérique qui réécrit les
règles sociales et nous oblige à
réinventer ce droit continental ou
depuis tant de siècles
nous avons voulu que la norme respecte
l'homme c'est enfin le défi de
l'humanisme contemporain
face au danger du fanatisme du
terrorisme de la guerre auxquelles nous
répondrons par une défense plus
européenne en cours d'édification mais
aussi par une europe de la culture et de
l'innovation
la paix n'est pas seulement le socle de
l'europe
elle en est l'idéal toujours à
promouvoir et seule l'europe et la
france en europe aujourd'hui
peuvent-ils parvenir alors oui nous
romprons avec les facilités que nous
nous étions donnés au cours des années
précédentes pour être à la hauteur de ce
que le moment exige de nous fernand
braudel le disait l'europe ne sera pas
si elle ne s'appuie sur ses vieilles
forces qui l'ont fait qui la travaillent
encore profondément d'un mot si l'on
néglige tous et humanisme vivant ne les
néglige non plus
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
nous connaissons à présent l'entousiasme
des commencements
mais la gravité des circonstances nous
empêche d'en ressentir aucune ivresse le
terrorisme n'a pas désarmé nous
équilibres financiers sont dégradées
notre dette considérable
l'investissement productif encore trop
faible et le chômage toujours
insupportable la dureté de la vie est là
pour tenter tant de nos concitoyens mais
le peuple français nous a fait connaître
ses volontés et nous en serons les
serviteurs
il y aura de l'imprévu des oppositions
des moments difficiles mais nous ne
laisserons pas un instant tous ces aléas
nous décourager devant chaque difficulté
au lieu de baisser les bras nous en
reviendrons à l'essentiel et nous
utiliserons une énergie plus grande
encore j'y suis prêt je suis sûr que
vous l'êtes aussi car par notre
engagement
les françaises et les français
retrouvent leur fierté parce que nul ici
n'a intérêt collectivement à ce que la
france y joue une avance suffisamment
vite
le peuple français ne nous demande pas
seulement de l'efficacité et
l'efficacité c'est un instrument
et puis on peut être tout à fait
efficace au service d'une mauvaise cause
non ils nous demandent ce que la
philosophe simone weil appelé
l'effectivité c'est à dire l'application
concrètes tangibles visible des
principes qui nous guident le refus
d'être prise en défaut
et de clamer des principes dont nous ne
poursuivons pas sans relâche
l'application le principe d'effectivité
c'est pour vous pour moi pour le
gouvernement de ne jamais cesser de se
demander si nous sommes en pratique
fidèle à nos principes c'est à dire
d'abord à la liberté l'égalité la
fraternité ce que nous avons à accomplir
c'est une véritable révolution nous
sommes ici vous et moi pour renouer avec
ce courage français qui ne se laisse pas
distraire par ceux qui n'ayant su aller
nulle part sont en quelque sorte revenus
de tous nous deux
à chaque instant être à la hauteur de
cet espoir français par l'engagement de
tous car ne vous y trompez pas les
forces adverses continue d'être
puissantes
non pas tant au parlement où les
oppositions légitime s'exprime non pas
dans la rue tout simplement dans les
têtes en chacun de nous il y à un
cynique qui sommeille et c'est en chacun
de nous qu'il faut le faire taire jour
après jour en lui rappelant sans cesse
le devoir qui est le nôtre en lui
rappelant sans cesse le moment que
traverse notre pays et cela se verra
alors nous serons cru alors nous
rendrons le service que le peuple
français attendent de nous avec humilité
alors nous resterons fidèles à cette
promesse de nos commencement cette
promesse que nous tiendrons parce
qu'elle est la plus grande la plus belle
qui soit faire à l'homme
enfin un pays digne de lui vive la
république vive la france
[Applaudissements]